hey everyone I'm out of char from a
description we all know the importance
of a well-stocked pantry you never know
when the in-laws are gonna stop by and
expect you to whip up a meal thirty
minutes right but we are real foodies we
can do better than a little bit of
spaghetti and candy today we're kicking
off my future sequels movie series with
two of my favorite ingredients for
inspiring doodles and exciting dishes on
the fly
my first staple is fish sauce in my
favorite brand is Thai Kitchen because
it adds this mommy rich janessa quacks
Laver to literally any kind of dish you
want to put in the refrigerator after
you open it but it'll last three years
unopened in a cool dark pantry here's
how to use them add a few shakes to your
homemade or bottled Caesar salad
dressing if you don't want to open up a
whole can of anchovies swap the soy
sauce for fish sauce in your flank steak
marinade before piling onto corn
tortillas
take your Caesar a Bloody Mary to South
Asia by substituting washes - our sauce
with a little savory fish sauce my
second staple is pomegranate molasses
it's found in a tons of Middle Eastern
kitchens and is made by reducing down
sweet and tangy pomegranate juice into a
luscious sticky syrup sounds fancy
but believe it or not nowadays you can
find it in most of your local grocery
stores in the international sections
like maple syrup
it pretty much last indefinitely in the
fridge but here's some great ways you
can use it mix it into melted dark
chocolate and top it onto vanilla ice
cream rush in onto bacon and bake it off
for sweet salty sour smoky combination
or for a really easy party appetizer I
drizzle it on top of some salty feta
cheese and put it on a twisted crostini
so go ahead invite yourself over stop by
after work follow me home
actually don't that would be creepy but
with these great new kitchen staples
you're gonna be ready - Wow
anybody that shows up at your door
thanks so much for watching for more
great tips on getting inspired in the
kitchen be sure to subscribe to my
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abbey's kitchen